Hey youtubers, wholock week continues with
my breakdown of how I think sherlock survived
his fall.
I promised this the other day but had to postpone
it for some doctor who related stuff yesterday.
Something about a christmas special, new doctor…
If you’re just finding me for the first
time this week I’ve been doing a week of
sherlock and doctor who videos to celebrate
the christmas special and series 3.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Normally there’s a much more diverse science
fiction/fantasy fandom offering.
But special events demand special videos.
So let’s get started.
Number 1, the ingredients he needed One Molly
Hooper, an undocumented cadaver, a squash
ball, a network of homeless spies and a well
thought out flight path from the roof to the
pavement.
2 - This explanation assumes that it was in
fact sherlock himself that went over the roof
and not the cadaver.
3 - Starting from the beginning.
Sherlock goes to molly and tells her she matters
and that she does in fact count.
It’s a double meaning though.
Molly likes to count things.
But Sherlock finds one extra cadaver in the
morgue.
4- Sherlock falls from the roof in such a
way to do the least amount of physical damage
to himself.
He is injured enough to make it believable
to any passersby that he’s dead.
5 - Watson’s vision is obscured by a well
timed laundry truck and is knocked to the
ground by one of sherlock’s homeless spies
on the bicycle.
Watson never sees sherlock hit the ground.
6 - Sherlock uses the squash ball to stop
the blood flow at the point where watson takes
his pulse.
Not feeling a pulse, Watson in a state of
shock believes sherlock is dead.
But the body still needs to be examined at
the morgue.
7 - This is where Molly comes back.
Sherlock is taken to the morgue still appearing
to be dead and is then revived by Molly wherein
they switch his body with that of the cadaver.
They also alter the records so that any officials
investigating will find nothing out of the
ordinary.
8 - The Cadaver is buried in sherlock’s
grave.
9 - What makes this so plausible?
Irene.
Remember Irene did the exact same thing in
Scandal.
Even Sherlock was fooled that she was dead.
Loving to solve puzzles, she would probably
have explained how she did it much to his
delight.
10 - Mycroft.
Where is mycroft in all this.
He’s jokingly referred to as the British
Government.
He knew all about Moriarty long before Sherlock
did.
Based on this it’s likely that he knows
and is merely impeding any further investigation
into the matter.
Which is probably one of the reasons Anderson
lost his job obsessing over it, as we learned
in the mini episode.
11 - Why, Moriarty had threatened the lives
of sherlock’s closest friends.
If he didn’t make his henchmen believe he
was dead, they would still have gone after
his friends.
12 - Alternatives.
There are some who believe that the laundry
truck cushioned sherlock’s fall.
But both Steven Moffat and Mark Gatiss said
the truck has nothing to do with it.
All the best theories I’ve seen include
Molly helping sherlock swap bodies and sherlock
jumping off the roof.
It’s really the point of impact and the
body bleeding on the pavement that are points
of contention.
Let me know what you’re favorite theory
is and remember I’m picking one random subscriber
from the comments to give a twenty dollar
amazon giftcard to.
Paypal gift for international viewers.
I’m working on a bunch more sherlock videos
between now and the premiere.
Right now you can click here for my breakdown
of the mini episode and here for my top 10
moments on sherlock so far.
Thanks for watching.
High fives.
see you tomorrow!